[Musique]
messieurs bonjour nous vous recevons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne Youtube qui
s'appelle sinkeriew on voudrait avoir
vos raisonnements questionnements et
peut-être prose ou ce que vous voulez
concernant la géopolitique l'énergie et
les rapports de force autour de ces
questions-là on va commencer à notre
gauche nous avons Nicolas méillan
Nicolas Meillan bonjour présentez-vous
succintement donc je suis euh consultant
en stratégie euh sur les secteurs du
transport et de l'énergie depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années et euh en dehors
de ces activités je fais partie de deux
groupes de réflexion les éconoclastes et
l'association pour l'étude du pic
pétrolier Aspo France je vous demanderai
de passer la parole à votre voisin de
gauche bonjour Francis Perin je dirige
une société qui s'appelle stratégie et
politique énergétique et je suis le
directeur de la rédaction de de
publication pétrolière et énergétique
notamment pétrole et gaz arabe et la
lettre au AG africain Francis passez la
parole à votre voisin de
gauche bonjour Philippe cébille Lopez je
suis directeur fondateur du cabinet
geéopolia cabinet spécialisé en
stratégie et intelligence économique et
dédié aux questions pétrolière gazière
et énergétique de façon plus générale
accessoirement l'auteur d'un ouvrage sur
la géopolitique du pétrole qui s'appelle
géopolitique du pétle mais avec un S
parce que il y a plusieurs géopolitiques
et plusieurs points de vue voilà alors
on va garder la parole avec Philippe
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
plusieurs points de vue dans la
géopolitique du pétrole c'estd
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser il
y a plusieurs modes d'analyse en terme
géopolitique de la situation pétrolière
on peut se baser tout simplement sur des
questions de grands ensembles de de de
quantités de
normes alors qu'au fond chaque pays qui
soit consommateur auou producteur a sa
propre stratégie qui n'est pas
nécessairement celle du voisin et on
aura l'occasion d'en parler j'imagine
Francis pin Francis qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire de la stratégie de
l'Arabie Saoudite en ce
moment actuellement et depuis quelques
mois d'ailleurs mais ça va en croissant
et en embellissant si je puis dire ce
qui domine la stratégie saoudienne c'est
l'obsession de l'Iran ce n'est pas
évidemment complètement nouveau bien au
contraire mais la montée en puissance de
l'Iran ou cette perception de la montée
en puissance de l'Iran la levée
partielle des sanctions dont bénéficie
l'Iran depuis le mois de janvier 2016 le
fait que l'Iran veuille augmenter sa
production pétrolière ses exportations
pétrolières en 2016 donc avoir
évidemment plus de recettes au-delà sa
production gazière ses exportations
gazières tous ces élémentsl l'attitude
de l'administration Obama par rapport à
l'Iran par rapport à l'Arabie Saoudite
tous ces éléments là et quelques autres
font que en Arabie Saoudite les
dirigeants sont très très inquiets par
rapport à l'Iran et qu'ils ont décidé de
rendre coup pour coup et cela influe
directement sur leur stratégie
pétrolière qui traditionnellement était
une stratégie qui n'était pas
spécifiquement spécialement politisé
entre guillemets on a vu le 17 avril
2016 la réunion de DOA au catar entre 18
pays producteurs la plupart des pays
membres de l'OPEP l'Organisation des
pays exportateurs de pétrole quelques
pays non OPEP dont la Russie ces pays
devaient s'entendre sur un gel de leur
production en 2016 pour faire remonter
les prix du pétrole c'était une réunion
qui était préparée depuis plusieurs
semaines normalement il ne devait pas y
avoir de problèmes particuliers et
quasiment à la dernière minute l'Arabie
saoudite a dit non à un accord sur le
gel de sa production sur la base du
raisonnement de l'argument suivant si
l'Iran ne gèle pas sa production nous
Arabie Saoudite nous n'allons pas geler
notre production chacun savait que
l'Iran naccepterait jamais de geler sa
production puisque l'Iran a vu sa
production chuter depuis des années du
fait des sanctions occidentales alors
maintenant qu'il a enfin l'occasion
d'augmenter sa production il ne va pas
la geler euh donc dire ça poser cette
condition c'était garantir l'échec le
fiasco de la réunion de DOA ce qui est
arrivé il y a pas eu d'accord et C ce
point particulièrement important
soulligne à quel point la politique
pétrolière aujourd'hui de l'Arabie
Saoudite pas hier ou avanth mais
aujourd'hui est entre guillemets
contaminé influencé par sa perception
d'une menace croissante liée à la montée
en puissance de l'Iran qu'est-ce que
vous pensez du fait que les entreprises
Ben Laden licenci 77000
de leurs employés et
que l'Arabie Saoudite et les les les
pays de la région s commence à
s'organiser autour de fonds
d'investissement pour l'après
pétrole alors les fonds d'investissement
dans cette région ce n'est pas une
nouveauté le cowet a été le pionnier il
y a très longtemps sur les fonds
souverains absolument tout à fait et les
autres ont suivi Emira rabuni Qatar
Arabie Saoudite sous différentes formes
avec différents noms mais on parle bien
ici de fonds souverains donc ça ce n'est
pas nouveau dans cette région du du golf
euh ce qui par contre est nouveau c'est
euh l'annonce par le Prince Mohammed ben
Salman qui est donc l'un des fils du roi
qui est le ministre de la Défense qui
est le vice-prce héritier qui est le
président du Conseil des affaires
économiques et du développement donc on
conçoit que c'est un homme assez
puissant euh simplement à cet énoncer de
ces quelques principales fonctions un
plan à long terme euh jusqu'à horizon
2030 Vision 2000 30 pour l'Arabie
Saoudite il ne s'agit pas de se placer
comme on l'a souvent dit dans l'après
pétrole parce que les Saoudiens savent
très bien qu'en 2030 il y aura encore
beaucoup de pétrole chez eux et ailleurs
il s'agit de diminuer de viser à
diminuer la dépendance du pays par
rapport au pétrole ce qui est très
différent et ce qui est tout à fait
logique de la part d'un pays producteur
parce que être très dépendant du pétrole
c'est une force mais c'est aussi une
fragilité c'est un facteur de
vulnérabilité notamment quand les prix
chutent comme ça a été le cas depuis
l'été 2014 euh c'est une vision
ambitieuse elle a été adoptée par le
Conseil des ministres donc ce n'est pas
seulement la vision du Prince Mohammed
ben Salman il l'a fait adopté par les
autorités saoudiennes alors ensuite euh
bon euh 2030 c'est à la fois court et et
loin en matière d'énergie il peut se
passer beaucoup de choses est-ce que ce
plan euh sera euh couronné de succès
personne ne peut le dire aujourd'hui ce
qui est intéressant son quand même les
grandes orientations euh diversif
diversification dans secteur énergétique
avec montée en puissance du gaz et des
énergies renouvelables ce qui est
nouveau pour l'Arabie Saoudite les
énergies renouvelables et puis
diversification en dehors du secteur de
l'énergie avec le secteur minier
l'Arabie saoudite a un vrai potentiel
dans ce domaine-là avec la fabrication
d'équipements industriel avec les
industries de la défense avec le
tourisme tourisme haute qualité hein ça
va pas devenir la Costa Brava ça c'est
clair c'est pas le c'est pas le style de
la maison euh donc voilà c'est c'est in
resscent cette prise de conscience des
objectifs chiffrés derrière cette vision
il y a un ensemble de stratégies qui
devront être définis dont une stratégie
pour la saoui Ramco la plus grande
compagnie pétrolière mondiale qui sera
privatisée sans doute à hauteur de 5 %
c'est-à-dire pas grand-chose mais 5 % ça
peut faire 100 milliards de dollars pour
alimenter ce fond souverain qui existe
déjà le public investment fund qui a
quelques centaines de milliards déjà à
son actif mais qui devrait passer à 1800
1900 milliards de dollars d'actifs à
horizon 2030 et devenir le plus
important fond souverain au monde selon
donc cette vision 2030 de l'Arabie
Saoudite Philippe qu'est-ce que vous
percevez de la stratégie saoudienne
est-ce que la famille als Saoud est
connecté dans l'air du temps par rapport
aux grands enjeux
géopolitiques la géopolitique de
l'Arabie saoudite a reposé euh DEP P du
kunsy en 1945
signé à bord du croiseur du même nom
Kouni
sur un soutien indéectible et une
relation
euh très soutenue entre États-Unis
Arabie Saoudite le les termes était
simple les États-Unis garantissaient le
maintien sur le trône de la famille als
Saoud en échange d'un pétrole bon marché
bon est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est pour ça
que la famille als Saoud met son
opposition sur la la la disclosure la
publication la diffulgation des 28 pages
concernant le rapport sénatorial contre
sur le 11 septembre ces fameuses 28
pages à 750 milliards de dollars oui
alors sur ce ce
rapport il est clair que les Saoudiens
sont pas rentrés dans le détail ils ont
simplement mis en garde l'administration
américaine en disant attendez si vous
nous poursuivez enfin si vous permettez
au tribunaux américains de juger la
responsabilité du gouvernement saoudien
dans les attentats du 11 septembre on va
retirer une partie de nos avoirs en
dollars aux États-Unis le volume de de
de l'investissement dollar saoudien aux
États-Unis c'est plusieurs centaines de
de milliards de dollars 8 % du PIB
peut-être j'ai pas le chiffre exact donc
je préfère pas dire de bêtises euh
simplement là encore c'est une promesse
on va dire au fond de enfin une menace
de dupe parce qu'au fond c'est l'intérêt
de personne quel est l'intérêt c'est qui
personne je veux dire ni des Saoudiens
ni des Américains d'accord parce que le
dollar chut trait et les les
exportations saoudiennes de pétrole se
font en dollar mais est-ce que ça
arrangerait pas les États-Unis que le
dollar chute bah pour
l'instant il a plutôt tendance à chuter
déjà donc je sais pas jusqu'à quel point
ils veulent le faire chuter si vous
espérez une remontée des taux comme le
prévoit
la présidente de la Réserve fédérale
faut pas non plus que votre monnaie se
dévalue ou se déprécie trop trop
brutalement donc là encore c'est un
petit peu de mon point de vue de la
gesticulation et il en sortira pas
grand-chose par contre je voulais
revenir sur ce que disait
Francis concernant la stratégie
justement ou les stratégies des grands
acteurs donc Francis a mentionné la
réunion de DOA du 17 avril il y avait
une réunion auparavant en février
surtout entre la Russie et l'Arabie
Saoudite pour justement préparer celle
de DOA du 17 avril et il s'étaent mis
plus ou moins d'accord pour geler leur
production au niveau de janvier 2016 bon
en gros
euh ce qui a été moins dit c'est qu'au
fond les deux pays en janvier 2016
avaient déjà fortement augmenté leur
production ce qui fait qu'en fait Gelai
une production qui a déjà augmenté par
rapport au mois de janvier de l'année
précédente c'est un demi-engagement
certains en sont même allés jusqu'à
penser que euh finalement il s'agissait
de faire une petite place à l'Iran alors
là j'is qu'on m'explique mais bon j'en
suis pas sûr du tout euh et si on
revient là encore à cet
accord on s'aperçoit que la Russie et
l'Arabie Saoudite sont en compétition
ultra intensive pour approvisionner les
marchés et préserver le part de marché
euh à TR qui va gagner alors attendez
parce que là il faut savoir qui attaque
ou et et donc euh donc les Saoudiens
essaient de se positionner en Europe
parce que les Russes essaient eux de se
positionner en Asie par quel
intermédiaire leur compagnie pétrolière
à l'exportation c'est tout euh donc les
Saoudiens euh depuis plusieurs mois ont
vendu au raffineurs européens du brut à
pris discante pour essayer de conquurir
des pars de marché sur le marché
européen qui est euh quel prix du
principal marché d'exportation de la
Russie aujourd'hui quel prix du
discompte c'est quelques dollars par
baril c'est pas 1 % du du prix du baril
là actuellement il a combien le le WTI 4
45 ça fluctue ça dépend si on parle du
WTI du
Brent dans cette fourchette là 40 45
parce que c'est un peu remonté donc il y
a cette espèce de de de de de de
compétition en terme de part de marché
entre la Russie et l'Arabie Saoudite et
il se trouve précisément que ce sont les
deux principaux pivots d'un éventuel
accord
mondial c'est pour ça que l'Iran
aujourd'hui est dans une situation qui
est pas très facile et surtout si l'Iran
doit respecter ce qu'elle souhaite faire
c'est-à-dire augmenter sa
production peut-être bon il paraît
qu'aujourd'hui déjà en quelques mois ils
ont augmenté 300000 barils jour de
production par rapport à avant les
sanctions le leur leur mage de manœuvre
au niveau de la production c'est combien
c'est 2 millions de barils bon c'est pas
bien parce qu'il faut du temps et puis
il faut des investissements et puis ça
dépend de l'état des infrastructures
après des années des années d'embargo
donc eux prétendent les Iraniens que en
un an ils pourrait augmenter d'un
million de barils jour ce qui semble
peut-être un petit peu optimiste euh par
contre 300 à 500000 barils jour très
probablement ils peuvent les faire donc
il faut quand même trouver de la place
pour ces 500000 barils jour additionnels
euh alors qu'on a déjà un marché qui est
relativement bien approvisionné euh mais
je voulais ajouter autre chose justement
sur sur sur ces rivalités
euh russo-saoudienne iranienne en gros
américano-russe
américano-russe encore autre chose bah
le PCT du Quincy l'accord tacite entre
les saoudiens et les Américains je
dirais que les les Saoudiens sont
simplement la pointe de diamant
énergétique des États-Unis non pardon là
la pointe de diamant des États-Unis au
niveau énergétique du moins l'allié
parfait énergétique vous savez les
États-Unis il y a plusieurs façons les
États-Unis c'est pas monolitique les
partis euh républicain démocrat on pas
nécessairement ou en tout cas
l'intérieur de ces partis vous avez des
clans des factions qui sont farouchement
hostiles au saouiens on a vu ça du temps
de l'administration bouche les
néoconservateurs une partie des
néoconservateurs je vous rappelle que
les néoconservateurs sont en fait des
démocrates qui ont quitté le parti
démocrate pour rejoindre les
républicains et qui eux ont des
positions très souvent proisraéliennes
et au moment des attentats du 11
septembre ils ont décidé que la relation
avec l'Arabie Saoudite ne pouvait plus
être qu'elle était par le passé que
l'Arabie Saoudite n'était plus un allié
de confiance et qu'en plus bon il
risquait de de porter un de préjudice
aux intérêts israéliens dans la région
voir de soutenir des mouvements qui je
vous ouvre une parenthèse Nicolas Méon
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire de
tout ça alors je voulais revenir
peut-être sur le point de vue
énergétique de l'Arabie Saoudite ce qui
est intéressant avec le le fond
souverain qui qu'ils ont annoncer les
investissements dans l'énergie c'est
qu'en fait il nous montre la voix c'est
l'Arabie Saoudite qui nous montre la
voix la transition énergétique il y a un
autre pays producteur de pétrole qui qui
qui nous montre la voix ça s'appelle la
Norvège ils ont aussi un fond souverain
à 800 milliards de dollars et c'est le
premier pays qui fait des
investissements pour se débarrasser de
sa dépendance propre au pétrole un
exemple Oslo en 2019 ils ont prévu de
d'interdire la circulation des voitures
à Oslo l'Arabie Saoudite était un des
derniers pays à produire son électricité
avec du pétrole tous les autres pays
suite aux deux chocs pétroliers euh
avait remplacé le pétrole soit par du
gaz soit par du nucléaire et donc
effectivement ils font baisser la part
de de pétrool dans leur production
d'électricité ils limitent au maximum
leur autoconsommation pour pouvoir
augmenter au maximum leur leurs
exportation et puis il n vous aura pas
manqué que l'Arabie Saoudite est dans un
pays où le climat est très chaud et très
ensoleillé donc ça fait beaucoup de sens
par exemple de faire des des énergies
renouvelables des panneaux solaires du
solaire thermique coupl avec des
générateurs au gaz pour limiter au
maximum leur leur leur consommation de
pétrole donc ça c'est quand même un
paradoxe qui est qui est assez
intéressant à souligner l'autre point
c'est sur la Russie l'Arabie Saoudite il
y a quelque chose qui s'est passé en
début d'années 2016 la Russie est devenu
le premier fournisseur de pétrole de la
Chine devant l'Arabie Saoudite qui était
le le premier historiquement le premier
pays fournisseur de la Chine pour quelle
raison parce que les Russes ont accepté
de se faire payer leur pétrole en yuan
et donc ça c'est un changement assez
significatif et je pense qu'il faudra
surveiller justement l'Arabie Saoudite
qui est attaqué sur ses propres terres
sur la Chine qui se redéfend sur sur
l'Europe ce sera intéressant de voir
comment cette situation va évoluer parce
que effffectivement les la demande de
pétrole aujourd'hui elle vient de deux
pays elle vient de la Chine et elle
vient de la inde l'Inde qui commence à
s'équiper en voiture et qui va avoir un
partenariat privilégié aussi avec l'Iran
et c'est probablement d'ailleurs leur
premier leur premierers clients Francis
nous l'Europe on se positionne comment
au niveau de tout cette échiquier
géopolitique et énergétique comment se
comporte l'Union européenne voire même
la France par rapport à cette dépendance
et ces jeux
géopolitique alors l'Union
européenne s'est dotée en février
2015 d'une d'un projet qu'on appelle le
projet d'union énergétique
euh évidemment février 2015 c'est un
petit peu moins d'un an après euh le
début de la nouvelle de l'actuelle crise
russo-ukrainienne la Crimée l'est de
l'Ukraine et il y a donc évidemment un
lien de de cause à effet important entre
ces événements géopolitiques et et cette
décision de l'Union europ d'adopter ce
projet de d'union énergétique qui sera
mis en œuvre sur plusieurs années eu
cette stratégie énergétique elle vise en
particulier le gaz naturel parce que
l'un des grands problèmes que l'on
ressent dans les dans les capitales
européennes en tout cas certaines
d'entre elles et à Bruxelles c'est la
dépendance de l'Union européenne par
rapport au gaz russse et il est donc
prévu de diversifier les
approvisionnements de de gaz européens
de gaz il est prévu de développer le gaz
naturel
liquéfié euh qui permet d'avoir du point
de vue des pays importateurs une plus
grande marge de manœuvre le gaz on
l'exporte soit par gazoduc soit sous
forme de gaz naturel liquéfié transporté
sur des bateaux des méthaniers un
gazoduc par définition c'est un lien
fixe entre un point de départ un point
d'arrivée donc il y a une rigidité euh
le gaz naturel ligfié ce sont des bateau
et un bateau ça peut aller dans un port
et puis ça peut changer de destination
aller vers un autre port tant que dans
ce port de destination il y a des
installations de réception et de
regazéification du gaz naturel liquéfié
donc développer le gaz naturel liquéfié
ça permet ça permettrait à l'Europe donc
d'avoir plus de Marg de liberté par
rapport à ces fournisseurs développer
également les liaison gazière au sein de
l'Union
européenne dans certains cas vous avez
vous pouvez avoir certains pays qui vont
avoir un problème de pénurie de gaz ou
de pénurie potentielle de gaz lesquel
d'autres qui sont bien notamment les
pays d'Europe centrale et orientale
d'autres qui sont bien dotés mais s'il y
a pas de liaison entre ceux qui ont du
gaz et ceux qui risquent de ne pas en
avoir assez au sein même de l'Union
européenne on a une situation qui est
évidemment un peu absurde où au sein
d'une Union et union normalement ça veut
dire quand même un minimum de solidarité
ceux qui pourrai aider certains autres
pays ne le peuvent pas parce qu'il y a
pas les infrastructures de transport
donc les gazoducs donc développer le
marché intérieur de l'énergie en
développant les liaisons entre les pays
européens l'équivalent d'une Smart Grid
énergétique oui tout à fait et puis
faire en sorte que les gazoducs
fonctionnent dans les deux sens on a
construit des gazoducs Russie vers
l'Europe donc ça allait de l'Est vers
l'Ouest puisque la Russie c'est
évidemment le premier exportateur
mondial de gaz avec gaz Prom l'Union
européenne est très dépendante par
rapport au gaz importé donc logiquement
on faisait des gazoduc dans le sens
est-ouest mais si sur une partie de ces
gazoducs on se donne la possibilité ce
qui est possible techniquement d'avoir
des échanges de gaz dans les deux
directions on a donc par exemple
l'Allemagne ou la France qui pourrait
renvoyer du gaz y compris du gaz russe
vers d'autres pays de l'Union européenne
qui pourrait en manquer donc il y a un
ensemble de choses diversification
énergétique également monter en
puissance des énergies renouvelables
plus d'efficacité énergétique visant à
rendre l'Union européenne à l'avenir on
est dans le moyen long terme évidemment
moins dépendant de possibles crises
énergétiques notamment de crise qui
pourrait toucher ou de tension qui
pourrait toucher les relations entre
l'Union européenne et la Russie et dans
le contexte de la crise
russo-ukrainienne c'est évidemment une
hypothèse qui à Bruxelles au niveau de
la Commission européenne est un une
hypothèse qui donne lieu à plusieurs
scénarios et qui est évidemment dans
toutes les têtes Philippe on a parlé de
gaz auuc d'olé auuc et de choses comme
ça maintenant on va parler de la
Syrie il y a certains points qui sont
soulevés sur internet concernant le
soutien de la Russie à la Syrie pour des
questions de gazoduc deoléoduc ou de
transport énergétique qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire dessus est-ce que c'est
vérifié c'est véritable est-ce que c'est
simplement qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez l'essentiel des gisements
pétroli syriens sont dans l'Est or l'est
c'est pas la région que contrôle le
mieux le pouvoir de du régime Assad le
régime Assad est plutôt dans l'Ouest il
contrôle les principales villes
d'amas cralp
euh la zone front
enfin la façade
méditerranéenne donc c'est pas une
question de léoduc je pense pas euh ni
de gazoduc d'ailleurs palmir qui est un
site historique comme chacun sait tu
vois ce qu'il en reste il y a aussi oui
enfin apparemment il en reste pas mal
euh mais euh et au sud de palmère vous
avez des gisements de gaz euh là on en a
pas beaucoup parlé mais bon j'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit euh une des
priorités du du régime
Assad donc mais c'est peut-être une des
priorités russe de de pouvoir imposer
son propre léoduc pour l'Union
européenne
non non parce que
là ça serait pour apprision enfin pour
acheminer quel gaz en provenance de quel
pays le fameux arc chi qui irait de
l'Iran à travers le l'Irak et
rejoindrait la Syrie il faudra qu' des
zones qui nécessairement seront pas très
très favorabl au régime Massad quel que
soit l'issue on ne sait pas quelle
échéance du règlement de la crise
syrienne règlement il y a un jour et on
sait pas dans quel terme donc si vous
avez des CDES par exemple qui contrôlent
le nord par où doit ber l'oduc je lu
donne pas beaucoup de chance de survie
donc vous voyez c'est pas là on tire des
plans sur la comète sans avoir le
moindre élément ferme de réflexion par
contre c'est dans la théorie de de de
des Fing Tang de bon on peut toujours
imaginer ça mais le plus simple serait
quand même que ça parte de l'Iran que ça
passe par la Turquie et ça directement
en Europe puisque la Turquie est quand
même malgré les les
les les ou les interrogations qu'on peut
avoir sur la politique d'Erdogan
deçonerdogan ne sera pas éternel non
plus quoi qu'on dise bon la C travaille
bien dans région je sûr non mais en même
temps c'est quand même plus simple
d'avoir un seul pays de
it pour le gaz
iranien plutôt que d'avoir repasser par
ce Moyen-Orient très compliqué et
notamment l'Irak où là encore les choses
ne sont pas réglées du tout est-ce qu'il
y aura un Kurdistan indépendant à terme
on n sait rien les curdes de Syrie c'est
même
question que vont devenir les les
islamistes qui eux sont plutôt dans le
centre de la Syrie voir DAEs on VI on
viendra sur les islamistes je vois que
Nicolas rajouter quelque chose oui sur
le le l'histoire des des gazoduc qui a
quand même une histoire assez
intriguante si on s'intéresse un peu à
la région on a parlé du gaz iranien les
Iraniens partagent le plus grand champ
de gaz au monde avec les Qataris Qataris
qui sont le premiers exportateur de gaz
naturel liqufié euh et et donc les
cataris quand ils exportent ce gaz
naturel liquifié qui coûte plus cher
hein qui coûte 10 dollars du 10 dollars
du mbtu les prix aujourd'hui en Europe
c'est plutôt 5ll MTU pour nos auditeurs
ça veut dire euh million British thermal
units hein c'est la façon de compter le
le gaz naturel euh dans les unités
internationales euh et donc les les
cataris qui exportent leur Gal euh leurs
gaz sont dépendants du dtroit d'orous
dtroit d'orous qui est et qui pourrait
être bloqué par les Iraniens et donc ils
se sont posés la question d'enlever
cette dépendance et de pouvoir exporter
leur gaz vers l'Europe par
pipeline et donc euh quand on il y a pas
150000 pays pour passer du Qatar à
l'Europe ça s'elle la Syrie soit par
l'Irak soit par la Syrie et donc en fait
ce qui est intéressant c'est que Bachar
al-Assad était assez proche était assez
proche des des Qataris qui étaient ses
presque ses meilleurs amis premier
investisseur étranger en Syrie le Qatar
jusqu'en 2011 et ils avaient discuté en
2009 d'un projet de faire passer un un
tuyau qui irait du Qatar Arabie Saoudite
Jordanie Syrie Turquie et d'ailleurs à
l'époque Bachar al-Assad s'entendait
très bien avec Erdogan on le surnommait
son petit frère et puis et puis ce ce
projet n'a pas plu bien évidemment euh
aux Russes euh qui voyait un concurrent
euh pour le gaz sur l'Europe et n'a pas
non plus plus aux Iraniens euh et euh
Bachar al-Assad étant à la 8 euh donc
qui est une minorité des chites euh a
finalement décidé de mettre fin à ce
projet pour faire un un réseau de
gazoduc avec l'Iran et en 2011 du jour
au lendemain les relations se sont
coupées
entre le Qatar le Qatar qui devait suite
à cet accord apporter la protection à la
Syrie une protection militaire un peu
comme les États-Unis l'apporté à
l'Arabie Saoudite du jour au lendemain
et bien leurs armes au lieu de les
donner au régime ils les ont donné aux
rebelles
Francis sur la Syrie alors il y a deux
aspects il y a d'une part les ressources
et énergétique de la Syrie et puis la
possibilité pour la Syrie d'être un pays
transit pour notamment du gaz venant
d'ailleurs sur le premier point il faut
quand même bien garder à l'esprit que la
Syrie ce n'est pas un gros détenteur de
réserves pétrolièr et gazièr euh l'Irak
c'est évidemment tout à fait autre chose
l'Irak est un géant pétrolier en terme
de de réserve euh la Syrie avant
évidemment la guerre de 2011 disons
jusqu'au début de cette décennie était
un petit producteur de pétrole et de gaz
donc il faut pas en faire sur ce plan là
sur le plan des réserves il faut pas en
faire un enjeu stratégique lié à
l'énergie sur le plan de la question du
transit ce qu'évoquait Nicolas Nicolas a
rappelé que le Qatar est aujourd'hui le
premier exportateur mondial de gaz
naturel
liquefi à partir de leurs installations
de liquéfaction à raselfan sur le le le
golf ils peuvent approvisionner le monde
entier en tout cas là où il y a des
besoins évidemment pour du gaz en
fonction de compétitivité par rapport à
d'autres fournisseurs le marché européen
le marché asiatique le marché
nordaméricain même si ce marché va se
fermer parce que les États-Unis ont une
production de gaz grâce à leur gaz
noncentional qui augmente ils sont
devenus le premier producteur de gaz au
monde devant la Russie ils sont
maintenant autosuffisants en gaz ils ont
comme à exporter du gaz naturel liqufié
en février 2016 et ils vont devenir très
rapidement un exportateur net de gaz
donc ils auront plus besoin ils
garderont des importations venant du
Canada qui est le le le grand voisin
mais voilà ils vont devenir exportateurs
net de gaz donc il y aura plus beaucoup
de gaz à exporter ou plus du tout vers
les États-Unis restera les marchés
asiatiques et européens donc le Qatar
s'est doté à coût de dizaines de
milliards de dollars de plusieurs trains
géants de liquifaction les plus grands
au monde à raselfan pour pouvoir
exporter du gaz naturel lquifier partout
et par conséquent pour eux la valeur
stratégique d'un gazoduc à travers la
Syrie c'est pas très important du tout
on croit que entre le Qatar et la Syrie
le seul différent c'est cette histoire
du gaz mais on oublie qu'il y a quelques
autres petits problèmes entre eux
notamment la question de l'Iran la Syrie
est au sein du monde arabe le pays qui a
les relations les plus étroites avec
l'Iran et c'est d'ailleurs l'une une des
raisons pour lesquelles la Syrie n'est
pas vraiment en odeur de sainteté si je
puis dire aux yeux d'autres pays arabes
notamment les pays arabes du golf donc
je crois que évidemment on est dans une
région le Moyen-Orient qui est une
éponge à pétrole et à gaz et nous
parlons aujourd'hui de pétrole énergie
géopolitique il y a évidemment souvent
des raisons des des relations très
étroites pardon entre pétrole gaz
géopolitique stratégie dans cette région
pour autant il ne faut pas penser que
l'énergie y compris le pétrole et gaz
peut expliquer tout ce qui se passe dans
cette régionl il y a aussi des
dynamiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec
l'énergie et en pour ce qui concerne la
Syrie je crois qu'il faut pas trop
s'attarder sur des scénarios dans
lesquels l'énergie sera un petit peu le
le dé Maina oui juste sur la sur la
Syrie pass PhIP tout de suite après sur
la sur la syérie effectivement la Syrie
est pas un des plus grands producteurs
de pétrole dans la région ceci m un
petit c'est un petit producteur ceci
c'était un petit parce que maintenant
ils produisent plus grand chose ils ont
passé le leur maximum de production euh
au début des à la fin des années 90 il
faut avoir en tête que le sur le
financement de l'État syrien euh
l'argent qui venait des exportations du
pétrole représenta 40 % du budget au
début des années 2000 euh à la fin des
années 2000 on était à 25
% du fait euh qu'ils ont passé ce
maximum de production et donc ils ont
quand même dû trouver de la l'argent
ailleurs comment est-ce qu'on trouve de
l'argent ailleurs et bien ça s'appelle
les impôts ça s'appelle les réduction de
subvention au prix de l'énergie et ça je
suis d'accord que ça n'est pas le
facteur principal mais ça été un facteur
qui s'est ajouté en plus dans cette
région en plus notamment des des crises
qu'on a pu avoir climatique qui ont un
impact très fort sur les sur
l'agriculture les productions locales de
céréal et je rappelle souvent que la
différence entre une guerre civile et où
tout va bien c'est TR repas par jour une
des raisons qui a engendré les printemps
arabes que ce soit quand il n a plus
deond dans les les chevaux se battent
exactement Philippe on va passer à la
Chine à l'Asie je voudrais votre point
de vue sur la sécurisation des colers du
collier de perle et ainsi que la mer de
Chine alors sur le collier de PER
expliquer ce qu'est le collier de perle
en fait c'est un un maillage de point
d'appui sur des ports qui vont de la
Chine continentale en la Côtière
jusqu'au Golf arabou
Persique Chapel d'île
île port mais l'idée c'est de de d'avoir
des ports qui vous permettent de faire
Escal pour les tankerss pour ce que vous
voulez voir
voir installer peut-être avec l'accord
des pays enfin concernés euh alors quand
j'entendais quand j'entendais
sécurisation du Colet de perle
j'entendais sécurisation américaine du
collier de perle qui est à mon sens la
principale route énergétique de la Chine
qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez je pense pas que les américains
s'intéressent de très près au collier de
perles en soi aussi depuis 2009 oui mais
après les affaires stratégiques du
ministère de défense c'est un point de
vue très chaud le discours et les actes
les États-Unis ont cette vision depuis
l'administration Obama avec le pivot
asiatique donc là on est bien d'accord
c'est la nouvelle orientation
stratégique des États-Unis par rapport à
ce qui était auparavant plutôt une
relation transatlantique bon comm tel
qu'on l'a connu maintenant les Chinois
n'ont pas les moyens dans l'immédiat de
négocier
euh des
base
puissante si on exclut quelques et là
justement il faut distinguer un peu les
cas de figure les Maldives ou
ou le Bangladesh ou c'est pas c'est pas
guadar justement au Pakistan guadar
c'est une ville chinoise un port chinois
construit par des chinois habité par des
chinois c'est vraiment un un un un point
de fixation con CR qui peut amener
toutes sortes de projets ensuite ce qui
sera pas le cas des autres points
d'appui qui eux sont plus on va dire des
points d'appui maritimes pour pour pour
la la mer de Chine qu'est-ce que vous
pensez des revendications millénaires ou
millénaristes des des Chinois concernant
la la mer de Chine B c'est pas nouveau
première chose qu'on peut dire en gros
ils ont commencé à revendiquer la
fameuse langue de bœuf qui descend en
gros presque jusqu'à l'Indonésie enfin
ça un peu plus honneur heureusement
juste en face de l'Australie c'est
peut-être pour ça que ça explique le
contrat de 50 milliards des Australiens
à vouloir des sous-marins oui ça
notamment mais euh bon les Américains
ont installé une base à Darwin donc au
nord de l'Australie euh B il a 500
hommes je crois euh donc c'est pas non
plus euh énorme euh est-ce que vous
pensez que les Chinois s'attendent à une
guerre dans la région et est-ce que
c'est pour ça qu'ils construisent des
portes-avions fixes par l'intermédiaire
d'î créé de de de rien qu'est-ce que
vous en
pensez les la stratégie militaire
chinoise a changé depuis on va dire ces
10 dernières années d'abord il y a un
effort militaire en terme budgétaire qui
n'a cessé d'augmenter mais quand on
compare celui des États-Unis à celui de
la Chine il y a pas photo vol quel est
le volume de la Chine quel est le volume
des États-Unis États-Unis euh je c les
États-Unis c'est plus de 10 fois le
budget de la défense chinois donc euh
c'est pas ils sont pas dans la même
catégorie très clairement euh les
États-Unis ont différentes flottes sur
tous les océan avec des portes-avions
des unités de projection euh les Chinois
viennent de sortir leurs premierers
porte-avion donc on part de de de zéro
enfin les Chinois partlent de rien et en
plus ils n'auront peut-être pas la
dernière technologie euh euh en terme de
compétitivité par rapport à ce que font
les Américains qui continuent d'investir
donc euh
je sais que c'est un fantasme très très
européen voire occidental ce conflit
Chine États-Unis maintenant la Chine
depuis des décennies son
principal axe stratégique c'était de
rendre son pays inexpugable qu'on ne
puisse pas l'envahir donc c'est une
stratégie exclusivement défensive où la
raison a pas besoin de porteavion
puisque notre ambition c'est pas d'aller
se projeter
à à l'extérieur bon il faisait quelques
incursions en territoire voisin comme au
Vietnam pour montrer qu'ils étaient là
et que bon bon euh il y a eu quelques
petites escarmouches avec la Russie
aussi sur le fleuv amour enfin bon en
gros c'était on est chez nous et
personne viendra chez
nous maintenant c'est un peu différent
puisque la Chine est en train d'invenir
une puissance globale tout le monde le
sait euh que ces exportations sont très
importantes que donc les les les flux de
marchandises vont être de plus en plus
importants alors ça c'est c'est une
extrapolation sur quel type de scénario
de consommation mondiale parce que
l'exportation chinoise est en train de
baisser le système financier chinois est
en train de se casser la gueule ils ont
injecté à peu près 40 ou 50 points de
points de PIB dans leur économie pour
maintenir les choses à flot ils font
face à une une fite de capit
extraordinaire depuis que leur bourse
oquet
oui mais bon ça si vous voulez c'est les
aléas de l'économie au sens large et de
la situation chinoise en particulier
euh on peut pas dire
dire que le
le les problèmes financiers de la Chine
aujourd'hui vont
conditionner l'évolution de sa politique
dans les années ou les décennies qui
viennent euh il faut savoir que les
enfin la Chine est en train de basculer
d'une
économieellementrie lourde ça c'est une
c'est un dogme qui est souvent colporté
de la mutation de la Chine sur les
entreprises de service choses comme ça
notamment mais pas seulement et parce
que aussi il va bien falloir que il il
bascule d'exportation vers la
consommation intérieure bon ça sera pas
non plus là encore de de
de d'un trait de plume ça prendra du
temps ça posera problèm beaucoup de
problèmes peut-être en terme de chômage
surinvestissement sur capacité des
choses comme ça néanmoins euh il fautf
là encore quand on suit un peu
l'évolution de la politique chinoise le
président x Jinping actuellement au
pouvoir est en train de totalement
noyauter l'appareil d'État il a mis des
hommes à lui partout
et si demain il y a trop de contestation
comme il y a eu déjà cris comme il y a
eu des des révoltes il peu près 1000000
oui oui a de laance ENF en même temps
c'est grand
beaucoup d'habitants tout est
relatif à Paris si on prend nos
manifestations chez nous ramen 76
millions d'habitant je sais pas combien
ça ferait
bon
bref je pense que l'appareil d'État
chinois pourvu que le Parti
communiste puisse garder les reennes du
pouvoir et là je vois pas comment il
pourra en être trom en tout cas sauf à
faire des
extrapolations un peu délirant
bon a toujours l'armé comme quoi c'est
quoi les extrapolations délirantes bah
un effondrement du système quel
effondrement de quel système bah du
Parti communiste ah bah oui puisque
c'est lui qui tient les reennes et et
par contre il y a remise enfin reprise
en main du PC on va dire par le pouvoir
central à Pékin avec les campagnes
antiorruption avec tout ce qu'on veut
bon alors ça ça ça évidemment c'est je
je vais vous mettre une petite pause
Francis l'Asie la Chine la mer de Chine
et tout ça alors effectivement comme
l' comme l'a rappelé
Philippe on avait donc beaucoup évoqué
du côté à Washington ce ce basculement
militaire et stratégique vers l'Asie du
fait du poids de l'Asie dans la
population mondiale dans l'économie
mondiale c'est l'une des grandes
orientations stratégiques de
l'administration Obama depuis depuis le
début depuis le le premier mandat du
président Obama euh et puis donc il
voulait le faire pas progressivement
bien sûr et il y a eu des problèmes qui
n'avait pas forcément envisagé comme
souvent d'une part en Europe la crise
russo-ukrainienne et ses conséquences et
laanestité de réassurer de rassurer
pardon l'allié européen et et
deuxièmement au Moyen-Orient l'État
islamique avec la Syrie l'Irak euh en
Afrique du Nord un peu la Libye et
cetera ce qui fait que le président
Obama et ses conseillers n'ont pas pu à
ce jour et ça va pas changer demain
mettre en œuvre comme il le souhaitait
ce ce réajustement stratégique sur le
plan militaire vers l'Asie ça reste dans
leurs intention à moyen et à long terme
pour les raisons évoquées mais il a bien
fallu renvoyer au contraire des troupes
vers le Moyen-Orient que
l'administration Obama souhaitait au
contraire quitter quitter de de de façon
relative en tout cas au sens de troupe
au sol et puis l'Europe où on voulait
alléger le dispositif le dispositif
militaire par rapport à la mer de Chine
évidemment ce qui se passe en Europe
alléger le dispositif militaire
américain en Europe été multiplié par 4
le budget C anné euh oui ah mais
justement ça c'est la conséquence de la
crise russo-ukrainienne mais par rapport
aux intentions du président Obama et de
ses proches consiller sur le plan
diplomatique il y avait vraiment la
volonté d'alléger le dispositif
militaire américain en Europe et au
Moyen
pour aller vers l'Asie euh sur la la mer
de
Chine du côté des États-Unis on dit
toujours il faut que ces problèmes
soient réglés
pacifiquement on ne prend pas position
sur les revendications territoriales de
la Chine de X de y mais ce qu'on veut
c'est que les gens se mettent autour
d'une table et discutent et n'emploient
pas la force la menace de la force et
cetera des gesticulation militaire pour
faire peur et
pour conquérir une partie d'une partie
du
ça permet évidemment aux États-Unis de
resserrer leurs relations avec plusieurs
des pays de la région qui ne sont pas
particulièrement très rassurés par
rapport aux ambitions chinoises y
compris le Vietnam ce qui est
historiquement et bien sûr on voit
d'ailleurs venir depuis quelques années
ce ce
rapprochement y compris militaire
stratégique disons
stratégique américano-vietnamien mais ce
qui se passe en mer de Chine l'attitude
de la Chine pousse plus plusieurs pays
alors Washington a des alliés depuis
longtemps en Asie mais ceux qui
n'étaient pas forcément ses grands
alliés se disent à tout prendre je
préfère me rapproché
de c'est un grand classique depuis
maiavel ça n'a pas et puis du côté de la
Chine également il y a cette dépendance
croissante du pays vis-à-vis des
importations
pétrolières la Chine est pourtant un un
gros producteur de pétrole c'est le la
Chine fait partie des C ou si premiers
producteurs mondiaux de pétrole par ce
qui n'est quand même pas rien en matière
de production de pétrole on a d'abord le
le le super trio États-Unis Russie
Arabie Saoudite par ordre des croissant
en terme de production de pétrole
aujourd'hui et ensuite on a loin
derrière on a un deuxème groupe de trois
pays qui sont Canada Irak Chine avec
entre 4 millions et 4 million et demi de
barils par jour pour chacun de ces pays
les trois premiers c'est plus de 10
millions de barils par jour hein pour
chacun États-Unis Russie Arabie Saoudite
donc la Chine est quand même un grand
product mondial de pétrole mais sa
production n'augmente plus depuis pas
mal de temps elle est on va dire stable
alors que sa consommation elle galope
parce que sa consommation est liée à sa
croissance économique à son
développement à son industrialisation au
développement des transports automobiles
sur son territoire et l'écart se creuse
chaque année entre une production
chinoise stable une consommation qui
augmente et donc de plus en plus la
Chine doit faire face à à à ce à ce ce
gap cet écart entre consommation et
production en ortant de plus en en plus
de pétrole et ça c'est un facteur qui
préoccupe les dirigeants chinois depu
plusieurs années estce c'est un plateau
de production Nicolas Meillan sur la
Chine est-ce que la Chine a atteint un
plateau de production au niveau de son
pétrole et que c'est pour ça qu'elle est
obligé de d' importer la Chine a
toujours été très pragmatique sur les
questions énergétiques sur les questions
du pétrole effectivement on voit depuis
un certain nombre d'années que la
production chinoise autour de 4 millions
de barils par jour n'augmente plus euh
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est leur
ils n'ont pas de capacité de projection
militaire mais ils ont une capacité de
projection économique et les accords qui
passe avec un certain nombre de pays qui
sont les fournisseurs de la Chine en
pétrole premier fournisseur la
Russie depuis le début de l'année vous
avez ensuite l'Arabie Saoudite et vous
avez un certain nombre de pays comme
l'Angola comme
Oman comme l'Irak
aussi la Chine qui après le après la
guerre en a raflé un certain nombre de
concessions au nez des des pétroliers
européens et américains sur le pétrole
de l'Irak et ils ont un pragmatisme
extrêmement important ils savent que
leur croissance économique future dépend
de cette approvisionnement de cette
sécurité et d'ailleurs quelque chose
d'intéressant depuis que les prix du
pétrole ont baissé de de presque 70
% la consommation et la demande chinoise
n'a pas baissé pourquoi parce que la
Chine ch achète tout le pétrole
disponible pour le stocker alors c'est
vrai qu'ils n'ont pas aujourd'hui les 3
mois de réserve stratégique qu'on les
pays de l'OCDE
euh mais l'an dernier 500000 barils par
jour étent achetés par les Chinois pour
le stocker d'abord le stocker dans des
réservoirs en surface et ensuite recréer
quasiment des pues de pétrole artificiel
le créer le stocker de manière
souterraine pour constituer ces stocks
je crois que l'an dernier ils avaient
atteint 200 millions de barils et que
leur objectif c'est 500 millions à
horizon 2020 donc ils savent beaucoup
plus que nous les Européens que leur
futur leur croissance et le le le
maintien de leur système qui dépend de
ces taux de croissance dépend du pétrole
il y a cette politique de de stockage
stratégique que vient d'évoquer à juste
titre Nicolas qui est l'une du priorité
de la politique énergétique chinoise il
y a il a évoqué également une
diversification des approvisionnements
avec notamment pas uniquement mais la
montée en puissance de la Russie le
Kazakhstan d'autres pays le l'Afrique
l'Angola et cetera il y a aussi une
politique de contrôle d'actifs
pétroliers le gouvernement chinois donne
pour mission aux compagnies pétrolière
étatique et il y en a trois principales
la CNPC la China National Petroleum
Corporation syopec et la Cnoc China
National offshore o Corporation d'aller
dans le monde entier enfin en tout cas
là il y a du du pétrole de prendre des
participations dans des actifs
pétroliers pour avoir droit à une part
de la production qui si besoin est pour
être acheminé vers le marché chinois
pour contribuer à la sécurisation des
approvisionnements et il y a aussi une
politique de diversification énergétique
euh alors il y a le problème du charbon
la Chine il faut jamais l'oublier
consomme la moitié du charbon consommé
dans le monde à elle toute seule mais ça
pose bien sûr quelques petits problèmes
environnementaux pollution locale
considérable avec sans doute des
centaines de milliers de morts prématuré
en Chine chaque année et puis
contribution au changement climatique
euh c'est pas pour ça qu'ils vont
abandonner le charbon parce que c'est
leur charbon c'est une ressource
nationale mais il ils peuvent pas
continuer il pourrait mais ils ne le
feront pas à aller développer le charbon
donc ils vont faire monter en puissance
le gaz naturel y compris en ortant du
gaz naturel liqufié justement ce qu'ils
ont commencé à faire ils développent et
ils vont continuue à développer les
énergies renouvelables l'efficacité
énergétique donc il faut un petit peu
feu de tout bois euh mais c'est une de
leurs préoccupations majeur en terme de
politique énergétique et bien entendu
politique énergétique sécurité des
approvisionnements on est en pleine
stratégie en pleine géopolitique bien
sûr Philippe et je je juste pour
compléter non non non prenez votre temps
pour compléter il a pas de Justus le la
stratégie d'approvisionnement chinoise
donc comme le disait justement euh euh
Francis bon ils achètent des droits sur
des gisements euh ils rachètent des
parts d'actifs sur des compagnies
étrangère déjà présente euh prendre
l'exemple de Repsol au Brésil où ils ont
créé une une join venture où
euh la Chine prend 40 % des actifs de
Repsol au Brésil et Repsol c'est la
deuxième compagnie en terme de
superficie des gisements à développer ou
déjà octroyé euh derrière pettrobras la
compagnie nationale ça me fait penser
tout à fait à la même démarche que
l'Iran avait eu avec Swift quand il
s'étaient fait expulser de chez Swift
ils sont amusés à diversifier absolument
leur leurs finances pour éviter ça les
Chinois font à peu près pareil
c'est-à-dire qu'ils achètent des part à
côté pour pouvoir euh bah ils achètent
des actifs soit sous sous forme
financière puisqueen fait ça sera
toujours Repsol l'opérateur ce sera
toujours Repsol qui fera le job on va
dire par contre sur la production à
venir ils prendront 40
autre cas de figure toujours en Amérique
latine le Venezuela le Venezuela n'a pas
les moyens vu la crise qui traverse
encore plus aujourd'hui
qu'ier de financer ses investissements
pétroliers à travers les compagniees
Nationales PDVSA est-ce que vous pouvez
rappeler juste pour nos auditeurs
qu'est-ce qui se passe au Venezuela en
ce moment mis à part l'inflation que que
les fonctionnaires travaillent plus que
de jours par jour et que certains
fonctionnaires faut pas exagérer ah bah
il faut que ce soit les fonctionnaaires
fctionnair je présume que les ord
ménagères continuent d'être ramasser il
faut éviter les épidémies enfin je le
souhaite pour eux euh enfin euh bon il
se passe une crise économique qui était
prévisible pourquoi prévisible
prévisible parce que quand vous avez un
cours du du brut à 147 90 ouais enfin
c'était en juillet c'était le 2011
juillet 2011 donc juillet 2008 8 8 oui
avant la crise pour ça qu'on le fait
venir à chaque fois avant la crise juste
avant la crise et donc la suite donc
euh quand vous avez des recettes
budgétaires de cet endre-là pour un pays
qui exporte en gros pour 90 % ils ont
vécu au-udessus de leurs moyens ils ont
vécu au-dessus de leurs moyens ce qui a
financé les missions les fameuses
missions de de GO Chavez qui ell ont
permis de sortir un certain nombre de
millions de de véézuéiens de la pauvreté
donc là on peut discuter du bien fondé
de la chose la méthode de financement
néanmoins bon le le but en lui-même est
plutôt louable maintenant
ce qu'on faisait avec 100 millions enfin
milliard pardon 100 million un baril à
100 100 dollars on peut plus le faire
avec un baril à 40 du
coup quand on essaie de maintenir ce
genre de subvention ou de de de de
de d'avantages sociaux si on peut dire
et vous n'avez plus rien pour les
financer votre économie plonge votre
monnaie se dévalue complètement comme il
s'agit en plus du Venezuela un pays qui
importe l'essentiel de ses biens de
consommation vous avez plus on all
jusqu'au papier toilett imaginez pénurie
de papier toilette aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est la bière maintenant
c'est la bière bon la bière qui est la
boisson nationale au Venezuela ils
peuvent plus importer le le l'orge parce
que là encore les prix ont augmenté
alors que le recettes ont diminué donc
on va vers un système et sans compé
qu'en plus certains produits son de
premité sont subventionnés et donc sont
font l'objet d'un trafic avec les
Colombie parce que comme évidemment
c'est moins cher au Venezuela vous
pouvez le revendre plus cher en Colombie
il fait que c'est un un puissant fond et
donc le système économique vézuellien en
train de s'effondrer complètement mais
je voulais en revenir donc au pétrole et
à la Chine puisqu'il ne pouvaient pas
financer précisément leurs
investissement et qu'ils avaient par
ailleurs sans doute besoin de recette
annexe ça c'est moins dit
la Chine a donné à plusieurs reprises on
va prêté des dizaines de milliards de
dollars gagés sur du pétrole à venir
donc ce que d'e certaine façon on dit là
encore que le Venezuela après les les
relations un peu houleuses qu'il y avait
eu entre les États-Unis George buouch et
le
Venezuela étrangement ça a pas
énormément fait chuter les exportations
du Venezuela vers les États-Unis
exportation pétrolière euh elles ont
progressivement diminué au profit de la
Chine justement c'est il y a un système
de bascule euh parce que les
vénézueliens sont bien obligés de
rembourser une partie de leur prê en
pétrole ni 60 milliards d'euros 60
milliards d'euros hein les les prêts les
prêts de la Chine à l'Argentine ça c'est
l'exemple Venezuela exactement les prêts
de la la Chine au vézuela mais
effectivement ce que fait c'est ce que
disait Philippe ce qui se passe avec le
Venezuela é fait avec un certain nombre
de pays j'ai en tête l'Afghanistan ou 80
% des investissements direct étranger
sont chinois bien évidemment l'Afrique
sur toutes les matières toutes les
céréales toute l'agriculture les Chinois
ont besoin ont besoin ils sont pas
autosuffisants et donc ont besoin on mis
la main sur un certain nombre de pays en
Afrique et de régions où ils arrivent
euh ils construisent des villes et ils
récupèrent ils récupèrent toutes les
céréales pour pouvoir s'approvisionner
donc il y a euh quelque chose
d'intéressant avec la Chine dont on
pourrait s'inspirer en Europe c'est
cette volonté alors sur
l'agroalimentaire c'est vrai que nous en
France on est assez bien loti donc on
est autosuffisant en tout cas dans tout
ce qui est céréales mais sur le pétrole
et l'énergie on dépend encore à à 30 %
de la Russie que ce soit sur le gaz mais
aussi sur le pétrole même si le lien sur
le pétrole est plus détendu puisque
c'est un marché qui est mondial ce qu'on
a pas dit tout à l'heure et que je
voulais ajouter c'est que sur la partie
énergie effectivement après les ce qui
s'est passé en Ukraine l'Europe s'est
dit on dépend trop de la Russie il faut
que nous diversifions nos
approvisionnements et en même temps vous
aviez aux États-Unis cette révolution
qui y a eu sur le pétrole et le gaz de
rochemer qui comme le disait Francis
fait qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
autosuffisants sur le gaz sur le pétrole
ils en ortent encore 40 % hein il faut
aussi noter que depuis cette révolution
ils importent plus aujourd'hui de
pétrole de l'Arabie Saoudite qu'avant la
Révolution ils importent moins de
pétrole plus vous êtes passé de vous
êtes al je monieur amusé à regarder les
informations les importations
pétrolières américaines aujourd'u de
l'Arabie Saoudite de l'Arabie Saoudite
ah d'accord effectivement ils importent
il y a 800000 baril du Nigéria qu'
n'importe plus puisque c'était la même
qualité hein de Light set crude mais
donc mais donc les Américains on avait
intérêt si vous voulez à ce que les
Européens se fâchent avec les Russes
pour pouvoir leur vendre leur gaz ils le
font déjà par seère énergie vous pouvez
dès aujourd'hui allumer votre chaudière
au gaz et vous chauffer au gaz de schist
euh et aussi le pétrole parce qu'il
pensaient et probablement à tort qu'un
jour ils allaient être indépendants en
terme de pétrole alors ils en exportent
ils ont enlevé le l'interdiction
d'exporter qui G qui date du premier
choc pétrolier mais ça c'est pour des
raisons de de de raffinerie et le fait
que le pétrtrole qui produise aux
États-Unis ne peut pas être raffiné
là-bas car ils ont des raffineries qui
qui est plus adapté du pétrole extra
lourd et donc les Américains avaient un
intérêt à ce que les Européens se F
s'entend moins bien avec les Russes
alors que c'est l'allié naturel la
Russie avec l'Europe pour les pour les
années qui viennent que ce soit sur
l'énergie ou sur un certain nombre
d'industries comme l'aérospatiale et
cetera je vais passer peut-être oui les
alors avant pour le
chiffrer juste un chiffre parce qu'il
est je pense très il est vrai et il est
très spectaculaire en
2005 les importations pétrolières des
États-Unis couvraent 60 % de leur
consommation nationale donc un taux de
dépendance
élevé aujourd'hui on est à un peu plus
de 20 % 21 22 % donc en une dizaine
d'années leur taux de dépendance
vis-à-vis des importations pétrolières a
été divisé par 3 c'est absolument
considra
soutenabilité en tout cas on n'est pas
dans le court terme on est au MIN on est
dans un moyen long terme la question
c'est jusqu'à quand ça vient en grande
partie cette diminution très forte de
leur taux de dépendance s'explique de
deux façons d'une part une consommation
qui n'augmente plus voire qui a même
décliné un petit peu consommation
pétrolière intérieure des États-Unis et
une production pétrolière en forte
hausse depuis 2008 du fait des pétroles
dit non conventionnels et ça réduit
évidemment considérablement l'écart
entre la consommation et la production
il y a quelques années enfin disons à la
fin des années 2000 vers 2007 200008 les
États-Unis étaiit le premier
consommateur mondial de pétrole le 3ème
producteur mondial de pétrole et le
premier importateur mondial de pétrole
aujourd'hui ils sont toujours le premier
consommateur mais ils sont le premier
producteur et ils sont le deuxième
importateur mondial de pétrole derrière
la Chine qui est passé devant les
États-Unis par rapport à c'est c'est le
lien avec ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
euh ils ont d'immenses réserves de gaz
non conventionnel les États-Unis
ils ont des réserves importantes de
pétrole
noncentionnel mais sur la base des
données qu'on a aujourd'hui on peut pas
dire ils ont des réserves immenses de
pétrole non conventionnel d'où votre
question combien de temps est-ce que ça
peut durer pour le gaz très longtemps
sans sans aucun doute pour le pétrole le
département de l'énergie des États-Unis
dit on a en tout cas une dynamique de
progression de notre notre production
pétrolière jusqu que vers
2025 là on voit à peu près clair à cet
horizon là euh ensuite on est prudent
ensuite point d'interrogation il n'est
pas sûr que les États-Unis a des
réserves pétrolières suffisantes c'est
pas le Moyen-Orient c'est pas l'Arabie
Saoudite en dépit du noncentionnel
euh mais ensuite c'est ça c'est sur la
base de l'état actuel de nos
connaissances les compagnies pétrolières
vont évidemment continuer à se
développer à explorer à à faire
progresser les techniques mais pour pour
l'instant disons que jusque vers la
moitié de la décennie prochaine les
États-Unis vont être dans une situation
pétrolière qui sera fort bonne avec de
moins en moins
d'importations
au-delà il faut être prudent et ne pas
forcément se précipiter dès aujourd'hui
pour faire des des prévisions au-delà de
2025 2030 Philippe je vais vous donner
la parole concernant
l'Arctique l'Arctique on en est où
nulle part il fait froid il des
pingouins non c'est-à-dire que les les
les grandes compagnies qui avaient des
permis notamment au nord de l'Alaska euh
ont tentait de faire des premiers
forages et euh bon vous savez que la la
la la période propice à ce genre de
forage est très très limité he c'est
mois d'été et en septembre il faudrait
ALIR tout tout terminer donc c'est le
cas de Chelle notamment qui a eu pas mal
de déboir et donc on dit pour l'instant
on gèle sans jeu de mot mais donc vu les
prix par ailleurs actuels il est sûr que
l'article va pas être une priorité pour
la plupart des compagnies qui ont des à
partir de quel prix c'est intéressant
l'Artic l'Artic pour l'instant je vous
dis on n'est pas très opérationnel sur
sur on n pas beaucoup de d'éléments de
comparaison les Russes font des choses
dans dans dans dans l'artile soviétique
euh mais on n pas des éléments
euh je dirais très fiable et avec du
recul pour savoir combien ça coûte
réellement on sait que ça va coûter très
cher parce que c'est des infrastructures
qui vont être par définition très
spécifi et l'acheminement ça va se
passer comment par exemple si je vous
dis que le réchauffement climatique avec
le permafros pour poser un oléoduc c'est
compliqué comment ça va se passer bah
s'il y a le réchauffement il y aura
peut-être moins de permafroste oui mais
les sols seront instables donc et il y
aura les bateaux il y aura les bateaux
donc là je redonne la parole tout de
suite à passage du Nord-Ouest donc les
les routes vont
racourc non le sur l'Arctique je crois
qu' il y a déjà aujourd'hui et depuis
des années une
réalité de des développements et de
l'exploitation pétrolière et gazière en
Arctique c'est le cas aux États-Unis
avec l'Alaska qui est un État producteur
de pétrole et de gaz depuis très
longtemps depuis d'années c'est le cas
d'une partie du Nord du Canada c'est le
cas d'une partie de la Russie c'est le
cas d'une partie de la Norvège et puis y
a les ambitions danoise avec le Grenland
mais là on est dans l'exploration donc
l'Arctique c'est déjà une réalité
aujourd'hui pétrolière et gazière depuis
pas mal d'années c'est pas seulement
l'avenir en disant qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire de l'Arctique est-ce qu'on va
aller trouver du pétrole oui bien sûr
c'est le cas déjà depuis pas mal de
temps c'est pour ça c'est pour ça qu'on
a vu les les les les super tanker rentré
dans dans dans en construction à grande
vitesse là je sais pas il y a combien de
projets de de super bateau
d'acheminement de alors les supertankers
c'est pas uniquement par rapport à
l'Arctique c'est pas uniquement parpp
àque c'est par rapport au transport
pétrolier de façon générale mais
évidemment ça peut alors l'Artic ça
demande certaines spécificités parce que
il faut parfois voilà il faut des prise
glace il faut donc là on est sur les
coûts qu'évoquait Philippe les
difficultés technologiques et les coûts
mais l'Arctique c'est déjà une réalité
pétrolière et gazière aujourd'hui bien
sûr c'est pour l'instant très peu
exploité par rapport au potentiel qu'on
ne peut pas chiffrer mais qui est
certain très important mais là je
reviens à ce que disait Philippe il y a
la question des prix de la rentabilité
qui est capital avec un prix à 100
dollars par baril les compagnies
pétrolières se disaient oui bien sûr on
va développer de nouveaux projets en
plus de ce qui existe déjà et il y en a
déjà un certain nombre mais on va
développer de plus en plus de projets
dans cette partie du monde qui est
encore l'un des des rares zones
mondiales qui est très peu exploré pas
pas inexploré mais très peu exploré avec
un prix aujourd'hui on est sur 45 47 bon
en janvier on est à moins de 30 c'est
clair que c'est pas la priorité pour des
raisons de rentabilité on il y a eu le
pétrole et le gaz noncciel aux
États-Unis qui ont largement changé la
donne au niveau mondial plus le Canada
avec le pétrole extrait des sa
vitumineux ce qui fait qu'on s'est même
trouvé avec un excédent de pétrole au
plan mondial c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a
fait chuter les prix largement donc
quand vous avez trop de pétrole sur le
marché des prix très bas et encore plein
de choses à faire dans d'autres régions
du monde y compris en Amérique du Nord
pour une compagnie pétrolière qui agit
normalement de façon à peu près
rationnelle vous dites bon ben
l'Arctique bien sûr je perds pas sa de
vue la preuve c'est que souvent j'y suis
déjà mais c'est pas la région
prioritaire pour de nouveaux
développements dans les prochaines
années c'est repousser en terme de
calendrier ça reste évidemment un enjeu
stratégique important pour l'industrie
pétrolière mais à moyen et long terme et
plutôt qu'à court moyen terme et juste
pour compléter sur les questions
géopolitiquesut
de l'Artique on entend souvent dire
qu'il peut y avoir des conflits
pétroliers sur les revendications
territoriales des uns et des autres
c'est assez faux dans la mesure où la
plupart des gisements pétroliers en tout
cas sont le long des côtes et sont pas
sur des zones disputées en terme de
conflit territorial entre les pays
riverins de la
zone la Norvège et la Russie on finit
par trouver un accord en mer de baren
enfin il y avit quelques mini conflits
par
contre ça il faut le dire aussi c'est
euh l'essentiel des ressources en
hydrocarbures de la zone artique c'est
d'abord du gaz beaucoup plus de gaz que
de pétrole et donc dans la situation
actuelle c'est moins intéressant là
aussi je vais vous poser une dernière
question à chacun la question classique
de notre chaîne YouTube il faut donner
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
alors Francis la connaît déjà Nicolas
l'a donné la connaî déjà alors on va
commencer par Philippe ah bah moi
laissez-moi le temps de la réflexion je
la connais pas bon alors on triche alors
allez on passe sur on passe sur Nico
Nicolas
pardon la question ah non pas pas la
même réponse que la dernière fois
attention je me fâche donc un conseil un
conseil pour les les jeunes générations
une bouteille à la mer exactement je
pense que depuis 15 ans le monde a
changé
euh le monde est beaucoup plus petit
avec le développement d'Internet et
aujourd'hui j'encouragerai les gens sur
ces sujetsl qui sont compliqués qui sont
le pétrole et la géopolitique c'est
toujours important d'avoir un certain
nombre de différentes sources pour
croiser les informations et donc les
jeunes doivent aujourd'hui s'approprier
s'approprier l'information se créer
leurs propres médias en allant chercher
en allant lire différentes sources et
différents points de vue pour recroiser
les infos c'est ce que je fais tous les
jours dans mon métier et c'est essentiel
pour pouvoir se forger une opinion et ne
jamais ne jamais prendre pour argent
comptant ce qu'on vous raconte Francis
je serais tenté de tricher et de
reprendre ce que Nicolas vient de dire à
savoir que on a parlé bien sûr
aujourd'hui d'en jeux stratégique
d'enjeu géopolitique lié à l'énergie et
et bien sûr il y en a beaucoup c'est
aussi un enjeu démocratique l'énergie
parce que l'énergie ça concerne tout le
monde tout le monde est au minimum
utilisateur d'énergie tous les jours 50
fois par
jour c'est ça ce sont des sujets
extrêmement important qui pèse sur les
choix politiques économiques ce qu'on a
un petit peu développé partiellement
dans cette fa dans ce à travers ce ce
débat et et je crois que ce que Nicolas
vient de dire sur jeune et moins jeune
d'ailleurs sur l'appropriation par des
personnes par des groupes de personnes
par des sociétés de ces enjeux
énergétiques de leur de leur poids de
leur
influence ça me paraît un sujet tout à
fait essentiel ça nous éloigne un petit
peu des aspects technicoéconomiqu qui
sont très importants mais je concluraai
bien je choisirai bien comme tout aille
à la mer effectivement ce se rappelle de
l'importance de de l'énergie pour toutes
les sociétés du monde et donc les enjeux
démocratique euh lié à à l'énergie à la
connaissance de ces enjeux et si
possible à la maîtrise de ces enjeu
Philippe c'est bon
presque
euh bon je rejoins mes mes deux petits
camarades là sur le le côté
indispensable de s'informer et de
s'informer à différentes sources de
comparer les sources pour se faire sa
propre religion et surtout échapper et
ça c'est peut-être la la principale mise
en garde que je voudrais euh évoquer
ici faire attention au courants
doctrinaux c'est-à-dire aux gens qui ont
un prê à penser lié à des
idées du moment et ça on peut le
comprendre appuyer sur des courants
politique ou autre imp peut-être même et
qui malheureusement parce qu'ils sont
peut-être politiquement très très
impliqués ont tendance à pas toujours
avoir une vision très précise de la
réalité et choisir un petit peu ce qui
leur convient par rapport à ce qui leur
convient moins donc c'est pour ça que ça
rejoint le côté s'informer d'abord pour
éviter d'être ensuite endurcir son
esprit critique être sujet pas objet
voilà parfait messieur merci
[Musique]